everyone knows that at the beginning it
happens all the time
and then as relationships get longer it
doesn't we say it's because we're too
busy or tired or just not in the mood
but why does this important mood
disappear to understand excitement we
have to go back to the early days when
we were deeply in the mood pretty much
every hour what was exciting was our
ability to touch hold stroke in short
possess someone who wasn't entirely
within our reach someone who was
independent and free to walk away from
us and yet miraculously was choosing not
to do so expressed as an equation
sexiness equals possession plus freedom
the thrilling desire to be within and
inside the body of another person it
stems from an active mesmerized wonder
that they've allowed us to be so close
and somewhere in the semi-conscious mind
a worried sense they might not do so
forever
unfortunately liking someone means we
almost always want to reduce their
ability to survive without us in the
nicest way we relentlessly try to erode
the freedom of the person we love and so
gradually but we kill the very spirit of
Independence that had underpinned the
desire from the outset there's something
else that wears away at the sex drive
fear add that right sound asking someone
to have sex with us generally has an
element of risk attached to it the other
person might say no or even at the limit
sex is a request and in order to make a
request we have to feel reasonably safe
about rejection at the start we do feel
that safety because even though we don't
know our lovers so well we're
independent we have our own routines
options and autonomy if it didn't work
out we could walk away out of love we
throw away the supports to our
independent lives we knit ourselves
together you no longer have very much we
can squarely call our own anymore
we also have to make requests at them
all the time we want them to buy that
sofa we like we want very badly not to
go and see their parents at Christmas we
rely on their income while we go back
and study for a new qualification in the
circumstances yet another request seems
like it might be really one too many and
so we don't bring up that thing we want
to do with the mask or the thigh high
boots we no longer have the will to lose
face in front of our daily negotiating
partner it might just be easier to leave
things alone strangely there is one
thing that's almost guaranteed to revive
sex a huge argument of a genuine
possibility of separation major bus
stops have a curious habit of ending up
in the bedroom because they bring back
to light two things whose apparent
absence have gravely undermined sex
firstly the sense that you could both
theoretically walk away and secondly
it's the sense that you could though it
wouldn't necessarily be easy survive
independently you could if you really
wanted build up your own castle once
more recover your own destiny and greet
existence as an independent soul good
sex leads all this it's built out of a
feeling of freedom and of buoyant
self-confidence the very things that can
become oddly so scarce with time to get
back to the thrill of the early days we
need to learn the deepest and best
lessons of breaking up ideally without
having to go through the very sad and
painful process of
need doing sir
you